[Musique]
excellent mardi 16 février à toutes et à
tous bienvenue sur arte et france info
décryptage invités analyse c'est parti
pour deux heures d'émission tout de
suite des titres à l'assemblée nationale
adopte en première lecture le projet de
loi comportant les principes de la
république plus de 300 amendements
validé pour cinquante et un article qui
divise trop pour la gauche pas assez
pour la droite vote solennel de ce texte
phare du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro je
n'ai jamais voulu mettre fin au contrôle
d'identité rétropédalage ce matin de
claire et dont la défenseure des droits
obligé de se justifier après la
polémique suscitée ce week-end par sa
proposition de zone son contrôle elle
réclame une meilleure traçabilité de ces
derniers la contreverse n'en finit pas
[Musique]
face à l'inquiétude des variants du
cornât virus les déserts médicaux loin
d'être une problématique nouvelle elle
revient au premier plan
l'enjeu permettre l'accès aux soins et
au vaccin à tous alors que les médecins
généralistes sont souvent éloignés ou
débordés la campagne de vaccination
justement si elles piétinent en france
elle s'avère prometteuse en israël en
deux mois 44 % des 9 millions
d'israéliens ont reçu au moins une dose
et une étude nationale publiée dimanche
indique une baisse drastique du taux
d'infection et des cas graves parmi la
population vaque sièges
[Musique]
l'assemblée nationale adopte en première
lecture donc le projet doit confortant
les principes de la république un texte
qui fait beaucoup parler depuis une
quinzaine de jours avec des débats
souvent houleux si la majorité a voulu
afficher son unité la droite et la
gauche ont voté contre ou se sont
abstenus sur cette loi phare du
quinquennat d'emmanuel mâcon plus de
précision avec mona amoud et l'or en
direct du palais bourbon à la loi
séparatisme a donc été votée à
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure en
effet les résultats sont tombés sans
grande surprise le texte a été adopté en
première lecture presque sans encombre
347 se sont prononcés pour et 151 contre
c'est une victoire pour la république en
marche alors que l'opposition fait
grincer des dents est accusé cette loi
d'être un fou retour et de toucher à
plusieurs libertés fondamentales les
prises de parole dans l'hémicycle ont
été quelque peu enflammé certains partis
politiques se sont abstenus de voter et
d'autres vont voter contre je propose de
les écouter le texte est un peu un peu
racoleur et pourraient correspondre à ce
que nous attendons effectivement lutter
contre les séparatismes sauf que par
rapport à l' annonce initiale
il ya un peu tromperie sur la
marchandise ce texte passe complètement
à côté de ses objectifs
il n'a pas atteint les objectifs qu'on
était en droit d'attendre la lutte
contre l'islamisme est un problème dans
notre pays éminemment important et bien
ce texte ne l'atteint pas règle pas le
problème on en est même très éloignées
dernier point si j'ose dire il y a
entamé des libertés fondamentales qu'ont
les français on s'y oppose au nom d'une
certaine vision de pays
la fraternité l'égalité la liberté c'est
à dire tous les principes républicains
que cette loi est essentielle raffermir
ce qu'elle ne fait pas elle pratique
l'amalgamme sans arrêt et c'est alors à
la fois dans le débat malsain qu'elle a
installés c'est à dire que mon amie on a
mis la majorité à miami la table et la
droite et l'extrême droite se sont
chargés de surveiller chérir amont à ce
projet de loi déplaît à l'opposition
qu'il ne le trouve pas à la hauteur des
enjeux politiques plusieurs sujets
manque selon eux d'autres estiment qu'il
est discriminatoire
oui exactement que ce soit à droite ou à
gauche les avis divergent selon les
républicains plusieurs sujets manque
comme par exemple le voile ou encore la
radicalisation dans les prisons où
l'immigration ce projet de loi sur les
républicains et jugés trop laxistes sur
certains points à gauche la loi est
considéré la discriminatoire et voué à
fracturer le pays selon alexis corbière
de la france insoumise qui a pris la
parole dans l'hémicycle est qui et qui a
fustigé ce projet n'aurait bien pour lui
ce texte permettra au gouvernement
d'avoir la mainmise sur le la vie
culturelle cultuelle religieuse de
certaines institutions musulmanes de
manière punitive il faut savoir que ce
texte est riche de 70 articles et 144 a
maintenant il aborde notamment le
contrôle renforcé de plusieurs
associations ou encore une meilleure
transparence des cultes et de leur
financement
et finalement ce projet d'eau et bien
c'est un petit peu l'aboutissement du
discours d' emmanuel macron le 2 octobre
2020 aux mureaux où il s'est montré
ferme le chef de l'état a voulu donner
une image de détermination de fermeté
pour écarter toute connivence lui qui
était accusée de tergiverser sur le
sujet est bien la lutte contre le
séparatisme et est un des chantiers du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron le texte
sera examiné au sénat à partir du 30
mars
merci mon âme au dès lors en direct du
palais bourbon à paris le projet de loi
contre les séparatismes va t'il assez
loin ne va-t-il pas assez loin face à
l'islamisme radical c'est le face à face
[Musique]
et nous invitait ce soir dallas écrit et
délégué général du cfcm le conseil
français du culte musulman et eric diard
député les républicains et co auteur
d'un rapport parlementaire avec le
député a l'air om eric boullier sur la
radicalisation dans les services publics
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions ce soir donc sur sur arte
france
je cite on prédisait un texte clivant
enquirer tendre toute la majorité un
consensus s'est finalement apparu au
sein de cette même majorité des mots
signés gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui se félicite donc de ce
texte mais en bien de l'entendre au
micro de mona hamou dès lors les
oppositions ne le voit pas de cet oeil
trop selon la gauche pas assez d'après
la droite eric diard vous avez voté
contre ou vous êtes abstenu en tant qu
homme de droite tout à l'heure non moi
je votais compte d'orateur et nous avons
été 97 de notre groupe a voté contre et
pour 5 abstentions
donc moi ce que je déplore il ya des
choses qui vont dans le bon sens je
pense à l'article 6 et l'article 18 qui
ont été pris en réaction à la terrible
affaire de samuel pâtit il ya des
éléments mais j'aurais souhaité qu'on
aborde la problématique de la
radicalisation prison et malheureusement
ils n'ont pas voulu
la problématique du séparatisme dans les
universités qu'un problème de plus en
plus prégnant et malade malheureusement
ça n'a pas été évoqué les quelques
amendements que nous avons obtenu le
délit d' entrave ou moins que le les
préfets puissent retrouver l'agrément
sur le sport pour les associations
sportives nous les avons eues contre
l'avis du gouvernement et avec des
députés de bon sens du modem et de la
république en marche
donc j'ai quand même l'impression que
sur la loi sécurité globale il ya eu
quand même un vent de fronde de la part
de l'ale gauche de la république à
marche et du coup ce sur ce texte là on
n'a pas voulu troubler la gauche de la
république à marcher donc
malheureusement il y a des il ya des
trous dans la raquette le
n'ayez pas et je le déplore il ya des
bonnes choses mais il fallait être plus
audacieux et aller plus loin adele a
décrit comment est ce que vous vous
réagissez à l'adoption de ce texte en
première lecture
écoutez moi je réagis dans la mesure où
les lois qu'ils votent et même pas il
faut l'appliquer pour la respecter
je viens d'entendre le député parle de
séparatistes dans les universités je
m'inscris en faux les républicains
souhaitent que les femmes qui sont
majeurs et qu'elles sont libres ne porte
plus le voir interdire le voile à
l'université dans la mesure où le
gouvernement ne marche pas et d'ailleurs
même au niveau de la liberté de chacun
de voir sa vie et commune souhaite et il
souhaite mettre cette liberté à mal dans
la mesure où ses fins quand
l'appartement en gc
ledit séparatisme suis désolé c'est pas
de séparatisme on est dans un pays de
droit de liberté et chacun que sa vie
comme il veut donc ça c'est clair que
cela en est quand les ascendants les
prisons ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
c'était également comme se situe au
pouvoir la radicalisation x6 et dans les
prisons la radicalisation existe
également par des raisons internes elle
mais uniquement quand j'entends certains
parler quand je souris ou comme certains
de leurs deux du front national et des
républicains c'est à dire y met tout le
monde dans le même sac c'est à dire en
revanche ce sont tous des radicaux
nous sommes tous sur le var nous sommes
tous des marais le leader séparatiste ne
sont pas des séparatistes on n'a jamais
demandé
séparée de la france et quand la
rappelle jacques dumas guerrand soir les
maux de la france non à malik 7 par
certaines personnes qui sont sous les
chênes ans commence à tourner en mémoire
la france
si l'islam et les musulmans les génois
et dessins et les musulmans il en a
marre d'entendre déjà envoyé des matins
j'en ai contre le tien minorité je cache
ma oui combien des tribunaux vite et de
les écrire je vous propose de regarder
cette infographie concernant la charte
des principes de la république trois
fédérations du cfcm sur les neuf noms
n'ont pas signé la charte et la grande
mosquée de saint denis de la réunion
fait cavalier seul cette charte des
principes républicains n'ont ratifié
ça veut dire quoi le texte on fait trop
c'est ça l'islam ne veut pas être
compatible avec la république comment
est-ce que vous analysez sa fédération
ont signé une victime en trois campagnes
et je suis allé visiter les mosquées de
la réunion ils ont insisté le qitâl 2010
905 et ça soit complété sa soirée avec
les autorités religieuses de la région
du centre est satisfait des rapports
avec l'islam
donc pourquoi rares et leur demander de
n'accepter que déjà ils sont avec lui
chez eux ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point il y a trois fédérations
de générations futures et une tenue sans
et pratiques qui n'ont pas voulu signer
et qu'il dise on souhaite le texan
à ce moment là il fallait peut-être
attendre que le texte soit revu
mais vu l'urgence ce qu'elle implique
son index a choisi d rapidement ça va se
dessiner mais l'essentiel y a cinq
fédérations qui en signer une liste
l'intérieur de la république il dit moi
je travaille avec ceux qui ont signé
dans une banque en cinq ans ce n est pas
parce que la proie qui n'ont pas signé
compatir que tous les musulmans
sans rentrer malgré les mêmes touches à
détroit quiconque à signer leurs
adhérents ne pas faire de l'étude
certains sont pas d'accord avec eux il
aurait souhaité qu'ils 6h à eric diard
votre réaction
mais ma réaction qui n'a pas du tout
compris ce que j'ai dit premièrement
quinze jours on parle de séparatisme
dans les universités je n'ai nullement à
employer le mot de voile je vous signale
que je vous invite à lire le contre
projet républicain
on ne parle pas du tout d'interdire le
voile à l'université le séparatisme dans
les universités c'est eux des personnes
qui refusent que dès que des hommes
rendant certaines réunions qui refusent
que des hommes qui soit de couleur
blanche rentrer dans réunion c'est
françois hollande qui est filtrée d'une
université donc c'est ça le séparatisme
dans les universités et moi je dis que
la très grande majorité des musulmans
respectent les valeurs de la république
le plus grand de vos ennemis ce sont les
fondamentalistes religieux et nous
sommes tous ensemble pour lutter donc
moi car je vous parle de séparatisme
dans les universités c'est nullement
question du voile
il est question d'association et parfois
c'est pas du séparatisme musulman cd
indigéniste cdd colonialiste qui
commence à vouloir imposer leurs idées
dans les universités enfin pour les
prisons c'est pas parce que le problème
est ancien qui ne faut pas attaquer le
mal par la racine
ça fait trop longtemps qu'il ya le
prosélytisme dans les prisons il faut
isoler j'allais dire les prosélytes des
autres personnes parce que il ya trop
d'individus qui sont rendus de prison
pour des faits de droits communs et qui
en ressortent radicalisé mais en aucun
cas il faut stigmatiser l'ensemble des
musulmans je sais que cette loi peut
déranger parce que certaines votre
communauté
eux se sentent stigmatisés il faut le
redire
qu'ils aient visé à travers cette loi
j'allais dire les deux individus
fondamentalistes malheureusement je vous
dis certains pans entiers de notre
société ne sont pas concernés par cette
loi
je ne dis pas qu'il fallait aller loin
dans certains domaines mais par exemple
je vous donne un autre exemple il a
fallu se battre dans le domaine du sport
il ya trop de problèmes de personnes qui
ne respectent pas les valeurs la
république et vous vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous voyez les trois
associations qui ne respectent pas la
charte se veut dire qu'elle ne
reconnaissent pas les valeurs de la
république ça veut dire qu'elle ne
reconnaissent pas l'égalité
hommes-femmes
ça veut dire qu elle ne condamne pas
j'allais dire le déni d' apostasie ça
veut dire que une personne qui refuse la
religion c'est la posta pour certains
d'entre eux c'est un criminel
ça ça n'existe pas cela de doit pas
avoir cours dans notre pays
et moi je vous dis nous sommes ensemble
s'il faut chasser ces fondamentalistes
parce que la très grande majorité
d'entre vous entrez dans la république
messieurs je vous propose de regarder ce
tweet de danielle simonnet conseillère
la france est soumise de paris
la loi séparatisme confond lutte contre
le terrorisme et contre l'intégrisme
or pour lutter contre le terrorisme il
faut d'abord des moyens pour le
renseignement il n'y avait que 30
personnes dans le dispositif
au moment de l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit eric diard ce projet de loi lutte
t-il contre le
suffisamment contre l'islamisme radical
contre les prêcheurs de haine par
exemple il ya ce fameux article 44
votaient ce week end
il ya des éléments intéressants qui vont
dans le bon sens e
mais attention ce que je déplorais on
vote contre par exemple vous voyez le
rapporteur général disait mais moi je
veux lutter contre le séparatisme
mais ce ce texte n'aborde pas la
radicalisation
attention il ya une zone grise entre le
séparatisme et la radicalisation
à partir de quand votre avec des gens
c'est par ici et à partir de quand on
bascule dans la radicalisation
donc moi je voyais ce que disait madame
simonet qui sait ça veut dire quoi les
renseignements il avait 30
mais s'il y en avait 30 sur le dossier
de samuel pâtit je trouve que c'est
quand même un nombre suffisant le
renseignement les effectifs montent
c'est pas facile mais il faut pouvoir
isoler j'allais dire les personnes dans
le haut du spectre
c'est à dire les plus dangereuses celles
qui sont susceptibles malheureusement de
passer à l'acte et de basculer dans la
radicalisation et puis après dans le
terrorisme
beaucoup de points évidemment dans cette
dans ce projet de loi on a évoqué le
donc cette radicalisation dans les
prisons selon vous qui n'est qui n'est
pas abordé donc du coup eric diard la
question du voile de la dcri la question
également de l'article 44 avec avec les
prêcheurs de
abdellah zekri une question qui a été
posée là par eric diard à partir de
quand est-ce qu'on bascule dans le
séparatisme à partir de quand est-ce
qu'on bascule dans la radicalisation
vous savez le séparatiste sous le masque
dans séparatisme quand on dit qu'on
n'aime pas la france veut séparer la
france
je n'ai pas entendu un responsable
musulman dans une mosquée merci qui
n'ont pas cédé à la charte de dire qu'on
veut se couper de la république ou de la
france dans le séparatisme pour moi
c'est déjà vous savez quand on habite à
neuilly comme la ville dans le 16e et
dans le 8ème arrondissement
on ne sépare est séparé des autres à ce
que la grande vie en vase clos
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point moi je n'ai pas dit que
le député gilles carle est alors allé
deux fois là moi je parle j'ai entendu
le leur chef de file
monsieur ciotti à l'assemblée nationale
tu te parler d' interdire le paintball
et j'ai décidé que je lui dis nous c'est
la raison des nationale c'est damien
abad c'est à eric ciotti je n'ai pas
terminé ça je n'ai entendu maintenant
les pêcheurs il y à 2508 recul d'à peu
près je n'ai pas entendu un imam et
avait près de troyes france
ça se passe par les réseaux sociaux il y
à quelques abrutis que c'est par
l'expression que d'être qui veulent
amener parce que dans tous les pièges
sans s'oublier
maintenant les fidèles il faut faire
attention départ côté corps le prêche de
même dans les bosquets à l'apa ya imams
de mosquées sur lequel qui a été expulsé
pour des prêches de haine contre la
france la stasi
je n'ai pas entendu mais ça existe dans
certains des billards à en dire au moyen
orient mais je n'ai pas entendu un
animal dans son prêche et je suis je
tourne je suis sur toulouges ce sera
marseille je bouge pas tout je n'ai pas
entendu animal dire si tu veut
abandonner dans les jambes rayman pour
épouser la volée sans juives chrétiennes
tu es là pour ça et qu'il faut
les catholiques il m'arrive d'aller
jouer à ce que c'est parce que j'étais
maison jeu et je respecte les gens d or
et je demande quand ça va bien
eric diard abdellah zekri a soulevé une
question intéressante sur la haine en
ligne les réseaux sociaux c'est
important ça bien sûr c'était pourtant
alors je dirais quand même il a donné
une partie de réponse il dit il n'y a
pas d' imam qui prêchent la haine parce
que c'est surveillé
c'est justement parce que c'est
surveillé et que les mosquées sont
surveillés qui a peu d'imams parce que
il y en a quelques-uns qui ont été
expulsées parce qu'il prêchait la haine
il y en a 1 notamment qui prêchait la
haine à marseille et je vous signale
qu'il ya trois ans et expulsé en algérie
donc il y en a très peu parce que c'est
surveillé bien évidemment il ya la haine
en ligne mais je vous signale que donc
la charte des valeurs
il ya parmi les trois qui ont pas signé
si à cause de rejeter la que 2 kilos
qu'ils ne veulent pas ne pas condamner
lazer nos phobies
ils ne veulent pas ils rejettent les
apostats et ça ça existe et c'est dans
ces trois mouvements et ça a été dit par
mohamed sifaoui ça a été reconnue donc
je vous rappelle que notre chef c'est
damien abad et je vous signale que même
dans les rangs de la réponse non mais
dans les rangs de la république à marche
il ya là aussi il y avait des personnes
qui voulaient interdire le voile à
l'université d'autres n'en veulent pas
nous moi je préfère parler plutôt du
voile des mineurs qui posait plus une
question qui met rennes méritait un
débat le voile à l'université on est sur
des majeures donc je voulais dit dans
notre contre projet ça n'a pas été
évoquée mais il ya une diversité de
députés aussi bien la république un
marche que chez nous qui ont des avis
différents et et moi je vous le dis je
ne souhaitais pas qu'on aborde encore
l'université il ya d'autres problèmes
plus importants par rapport à le
séparatisme et notamment quand nous est
dit dans le sport qui a été quand même
plutôt bien aborder maintenant mais un
peu contre l'avis de la ministre des
sports et surtout il manque les prisons
les universités et ça risque de faire
des trous dans la raquette mais si on a
on a vu tout à l'heure le tweet
dune
d'une politique de gauche danielle
simonnet je vous propose un réaction
d'un homme politique d'extrême droite
sébastien schmitt porte parole du
rassemblement national et député est
reine du nord ce texte vient taquiner
l'idéologie islamiste alors qu'il faut
la combattre
l'interdire l'expulser il faut être
d'une fermeté sans faille
il n'y a rien de tout ça est bien là et
crée quand on écoute sébastien chenu ça
ne va pas assez loin votre réaction
sami je voudrais dire à celle qui parle
de l'image de marseille est expulsé je
veux rassurer parce que j'avais demandé
ce qu'on sait c'est le premier point
maintenant vous revenez toujours à la
chatte d'achat pour le moment là les
cinémas que cette fédération alors avec
son chemin
je vais vous donner l'information fait
vous n'êtes pas au courant avait été
transmise dans les régions encore train
de travailler personnellement j'étais
déjà devenir un taudis penche dessus
la vie sera belle l'embase qu'est-ce qui
tel le modifier dans sasha
qu'est ce qui va leur demander qu'est-ce
qui va rajouter pour qu'il puisse y
avoir un débat
cette règle du jeu je le dis et je le
répète il faut pas faire d'une minorité
qui est il en train de semer la pagaille
ou qui a porté atteinte aux valeurs qui
est la république ou qui ne veut pas
dire que c'est tout le monde maintenant
vous m'avez dit monsieur le député aussi
parce que les ide en ce sens mais non
c'est pas parce que je sens où vais je
ne sais pas l'exprimer
ces mêmes savent très bien ce qu'ils
disent pas ce que ya des fidèles
tout le monde sait le connaître des
secours et je peux vous assurer que la
grande grande comme majorité des
recettes locales
moi ce que j'attends des imams dans leur
discours
dans leur prêche c'est alerter les
jeunes de ne pas aller sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant ces marchands de ces
marchands de mort on est en train de
vivre ici parce que les à l'europe et au
piment propre pays et aider m merci
abdallah zekri est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
délégué général du cfcm merci également
à vous eric diard député l ère des
bouches du rhône auteur donc d'un
rapport parlementaire sur la
radicalisation dans les services publics
une polémique qui n'en finit pas celles
nées de la proposition le week-end
dernier de la défenseure des droits de
créer des zones sans contrôle d'identité
selon claire hédon dans 95% des cas les
contrôles d'identité ne donne rien elle
pointe
répétition du processus je cite
insupportable pour certains jeunes
mais ce matin volte face au micro
d'europe 1 je n'ai jamais souhaité
mettre fin au contrôle d'identité
claire hédon dit vouloir d'abord la mise
en place d'une meilleure traçabilité de
ces contrôles pour lutter contre les
discriminations
la controverse ne désenfle pas le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
il ya opposé une fin de non-recevoir
lors d'un déplacement hier soir à poissy
dans les yvelines a pour revenir donc
sur cette polémique et cette surenchère
sécuritaire qui s'impose dans le débat
politique
alexis poulain c'est l'édito bonsoir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france donc la défenseure
des lois des droits à semer le trouble
avec une proposition d'expérimentation
de zone sans contrôle d'identité oui
alors cette proposition comme vous venez
de le dire a suscité un vif débat était
très mal reçue par les syndicats de
policiers qui ont parlé de fan zone pour
les délinquants qui ont rappelé aussi la
continuité de la loi et du droit qui
doit être la même pour tous et partout
sur le territoire
donc pourquoi vouloir à certains
endroits à voir des zones
d'expérimentation de nos contrôles
d'identité elle est revenu bien sûr elle
a levé l'ambiguïté
il y avait également stanislas guérini
un responsable du parti la république en
marche qui dit que c'était un recul
phénoménal de la république mais il faut
rappeler d'où vient cette idée
finalement elle vient de l'interview
qu'avait donnée macro président de la
république fondateur du parti la
république en marche à brut
lorsqu'il disait qu effectivement il y
avait des délits de contrôle au faciès
et qu'il fallait y remédier et que donc
il allait ouvrir une plateforme pour
dénoncer les discriminations c'est ce
qui a été fait par querrey dont la
défenseur des droits c'était le 12
février cette plateforme a été ouverte
va s'ensuivre une consultation de deux
semaines sur les discriminations et donc
quand on remet dans le contexte on
comprend pourquoi clairet dont a proposé
cette idée pour aller dans le sens
finalement du président de la république
c'est là toute la magie du en même temps
d'un côté mais elle macron dit quelque
chose de l'autre
le gouvernement veut en faire une autre
et la république en marche ne s'y
retrouve plus donc voilà où on en est et
puis il ya la réalité sur le terrain
pour les policiers qui reste quand même
critique
alexis poulain une polémique qui enfle 1
toujours avec autant de violence dans
certains quartiers en direction des
forces de l'ordre on l'a vu notamment à
poissy 1 ces derniers jours oui c'est ce
qui fait en fait que l'annoncé est très
mal tombé et a été très mal reçue par
les policiers les syndicats de policiers
c'est qu'on a vu cette vidéo de lynchage
de policiers par des jeunes qui au son
de tuer les tuer les avait pris en
embuscade
une patrouille de police et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui se répète
qu'on connaît les pompiers les policiers
qui sont appelés pour intervenir dans
des quartiers et qui sont en fait pris
au piège dans des guets-apens par les
jeunes des quartiers qui sont là pour
rétorquer pour casser du flic d'une
certaine façon et c'est inacceptable
évidemment le maire de poissy karl olive
lui disais que c'est très regrettable
c'est scandaleux c'est inacceptable
malheureusement c'est quasi quotidiens
ces scènes là on les a trop souvent on a
même vu des concours sur les réseaux
sociaux de quartier à quartier qui
filmait les fameux guet-apens et qui
comme ça essayez de voir qui était le
plus violent avec avec les policiers
gérald darmanin a rappelé que s'attaquer
aux policiers s'est attaqué à la
république il a voulu bien sûr revenir
dans le débat politique et c'est bien
toute la sphère en fait ce débat devient
extrêmement politique puisque on est en
train d'entrer dans des phases de
d'élections élections des régionales et
puis la présidentielle bien sûr qu'ils
arrivent en 2022 donc le débat revient
le débat sécuritaire sur le devant de la
scène mais alors justement vous parlez
du débat et de la surenchère sécuritaire
est ce qu'il y à une surenchère
sécuritaire pour la république en marche
a clairement très clairement d'ailleurs
c'est gérald darmanin qui est en charge
de l' aile sécuritaire pour aller
draguer finalement l'électorat de marine
le pen et du rassemblement national
lui-même a d'ailleurs annoncé
nous voulons montrer qu'il ya une
alternative à marine le pen puisqu'en
fait pour lui si marine le pen exister
parce qu'il ya des problèmes donc elle
n'a aucun intérêt à résoudre les
problèmes donc lui gérald darmanin que
fait-il eh bien ils créent davantage de
problèmes finalement en essayant de
faire croire à l'électorat du
rassemblement national que la république
en marche va être le parti qui va
répondre à leurs attentes et il n'y a
pas que lui d'ailleurs qui drague
l'électorat du front national
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui a eu des
sorties abracadabrantesque sur les
enfants qui refusait de s'asseoir sur
des chaises rouges parce que ce serait
la couleur du diable ou bien des hangars
où l'islam aurait était et inculquer aux
enfants lors des désirs des enfants qui
ne sont pas à l'école inquiet avec
l'enseignement à la maison vous avez
également marlène schiappa qui fait la
chasse aux petites filles qui refusent
d'aller à la piscine et qui appelle ça
du séparatisme et frédéric vidal
dernière en date ministre de la
recherche qui elle plutôt que de
s'occuper du sort des étudiants qui
tombent dans la précarité et bien a
préféré mettre en place une commission
d' enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme dans
les facultés françaises
elle a reçu une fin de non recevoir de
la part de la conférence des présidents
d'université qui ont dit que c'était un
débat stérile non avenue et qu'il
fallait arrêter là et c'est vrai que
dans la surenchère sécuritaire dans
l'assurance air islamophobe d'une
certaine façon au xénon fob on va dire
il est là une course à l'échalote de la
part de la république en marche qui
voudrait se présenter finalement comme
le parti de l'extrême droite efficace
qui fonctionne parce qu'au pouvoir et
enlever tous les électeurs finalement de
marine le pen pour 2022
et en même temps se positionner face à
une gauche critique pour les taxes et e
d'islamo gauchistes c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dangereuse c'est une
mécanique qu'on connaît qui n'a jamais
fonctionné d'ailleurs puisqu'il ne fait
que renforcer les idées du rassemblement
national plutôt que ceux qui essayent de
siphonner l'électorat de marine le pen
donc attention à ce choix stratégique
qui semble être une impasse mais
malheureusement rien n'est fait pour
siffler la fin de la récréation est
d'ailleurs la loi séparatisme et des
valeurs de la république vient d'être
votée aujourd'hui à la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale donc le débat
risque d'être encore longtemps sur la
table parce qu'à chaque élection
présidentielle c'est d'abord la sécurité
qui a été
un des étendards pour d'une certaine
façon montrer les camps politiques et le
en même temps malheureusement ne marche
pas dans ce cas là et ça pourrait être
la fin de la république en marche avec
beaucoup j'imagine de députés de la
majorité qui ne se retrouveront pas dans
ce virage à l'extrême droite deux du
parti présidentiel
merci alexis poulain pour vous précisez
vos précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes très bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous si vous nous rejoignez
sur rt france l'info continue il est
20h30 heure française alain fischer le
monsieur vaccin du gouvernement a appelé
hier à vacciner 17 à 20 millions de
personnes avant l'été la stratégie
française de lutte contre le coronavirus
passe par une campagne de vaccination
massive problème les déserts médicaux
une problématique loin d'être un
nouvelle mais qui revient au premier
plan comme en permettre l'accès aux
soins et au vaccin à tous à tous alors
que les médecins sont souvent éloignés
géographiquement ou tout simplement
débordé si les généralistes pourront
vacciner dès le 25 février le nombre de
comptes ont dépourvues de médecin est
passé de 91 en 2010 vous le voyez à 148
en 2017 soit une augmentation de 62%
d'après une étude réalisée pour
l'association des maires ruraux de
france et on en parle avec jean luc le
gall président du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins du var
bonsoir jean luc le gall merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce soir
en temps normal pas assez de médecins
sur certains territoires et en temps de
crise avec des jets rennes avec des
généralistes en en première ligne pour
vacciner
comment est ce qu'on fait d'autant plus
qu'il annonce un qui est tombé tout à
l'heure la vaccination chez les
généralistes démarre le 25 février
oui tout à fait la prise du coup vie de
augmente on commence la difficulté la
problématique elle en plus elle n'est
pas que dans l'est dans les cantons
roule pour le match aller les général on
la retrouve aussi dans des dans des
grandes villes impôts pour l'exemple de
ma commune à toulouse salle de quartier
à 9,1 des parts de 12 généralistes qu'on
attend trop timide et douze mille
patients qui ont du mal à trouver un
médecin traitant
donc s'il veut très compliqué pour ces
gens là d'avoir accès effectivement mais
c'est traitant pour se faire vacciner
comme il est très compliqué dans leur
médecin traitant pour se faire prendre
en charge ce que deux médecins présents
restent leur est débordé mais alors
comment est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce que
vous proposez pour pour trouver une
solution à cela c'est problématique
la solution je pense que tous les
patients réussiront le fait de pas voir
médecins traitants n'empêche pas l'accès
à la vaccination un certain nombre de
médecins accepteront de prendre en
charge des patients qui ne suivent pas
habituellement ça sera sans doute un peu
plus compliqué le chemin ce train sera
plus cahoteux et malheureusement la
solution c'est une problématique qui
dure depuis des années voire des
dizaines d'années qui était plus ou
moins avancé que les toits politiques
n'ont pas souhaité nous considérer au
prenant en charge on n'arrivera pas
régler cette problématique dans les
semaines ou dans les mois à venir
ça dure depuis des années on ne sait
rien c'est pas nouveau mais avec cette
crise sanitaire cette crise du
coronavirus ça revient au premier plan à
ce cadre du coup c'est pas j'ai envie de
dire l'occasion de sa paie acp à ce
problème et de trouver les solutions
il faut changer ça fait longtemps qu'on
aurait dû de claudy siar l'ailé
les facteurs les raisons sont
multifactorielles la prise du coc vide
là sans doute aggrave les choses mais il
faut savoir quand même que de l'huile a
pris du corry de l'activité des médecins
libéraux dans l'ensemble a b c en france
est sur l'année 2020 l'activité a baissé
de abaissé de 20% dans le d'abord parce
que en mars/avril eux on avait demandé
aux gens de rester chez eux donc ils
s'étaient des mois des mois où les gens
se sont pas pris en charge
effectivement pendant cette année aussi
d'eau de médecins sont partis en
retraite et n'ont pas été remplacés
les solutions erp pour les trouver ça va
prendre plusieurs années je largue
motiver les confrères à revenir vers la
médecine libérale à la fois en relais à
la fois dans les milieux dans les
milieux ruraux a créé des structures
d'accueil de deux activités regroupées
parce que c'est le choix des hommes des
jeunes générations a kiss in nécessité
impérative du fait maintenant des
complications administratives de la
profession justement vous parlez des
complications administratives
on évoque souvent
la lourdeur administrative les
millefeuilles décisionnel les ars
notamment les agences régionales de
santé qui sont pointés les
technostructures en quoi est-ce à dire
une difficulté pour les déserts médicaux
vous allez dans les airs musicaux il ya
tout un tas de mesures qui ont du temps
j'ai déjà été mises en place par les
différents pouvoirs politiques des aides
à l'installation de d d d aide à la
prise en charge des locaux l'éventuel
montant des aides aux sons des temps de
secrétariat tout ça je suis pas certain
que ce soit la rs au niveau des parts au
niveau départemental vous rendez vous
régional qui qui sont responsables de
ces difficultés à l'un d'eux ne moindre
activité attractivité du métier est une
charge administrative important que des
médecins en tant que tel dans son
cabinet d'un médecin généraliste menant
à mon avis ne peut plus démarre une
activité tous tout seul et son
secrétaire en tout cas dans quel état
d'esprit sont les habitants des
populations rurales face à face au
vaccin méfiance réticence ou espoirs a
contrario on pointe souvent un certain
scepticisme
41% des français veulent se faire
vacciner selon un sondage récent du 5
février researcher pour software
je sais pas si c'est propre population
virale je crois que pendant la même
chose le même pourcentage dans les
populations urbaines
on a aussi d'un certain nombre de
soignants de personnes chantiers qui
sont aussi réticents et tout un tas de
discours quand l'avenue sol et sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les médias qui
n'ont fait que quand régnait une
certaine confusion et certain
scepticisme
je pense que de toute façon l'état
actuel de toute façon n'a pas
suffisamment de doses pour vacciner le
carnet des 59 ou 50 % qui sont prêts à
se faire vacciner
la problématique et les régionales et en
cas de test positif au kobus 19 la rs
précise qu'il est possible d'avoir la
visite d'une infirmière libérale comment
est ce qu'on fait quand ça se passe là
où les infirmiers sont peu nombreux dans
les zones géographiquement étendue
les infirmières dans c'est pas ma
spécialité mais ils sont ils sont un peu
plus nombreux que nous ils ont une
activité les infirmiers libéraux qui est
un peu différent qui sont beaucoup plus
en association
ce sont des gens qui font quasiment que
du domicile donc ils sont habitués à se
déplacer chez les gens donc ça s'est mis
en place de façon très claire dans les
départements au travers des possédants
des infirmiers des associations et cette
facilité en général en tout cas dans
d'autres départements par les services
de la cpam match j'ai une dernière
question par rapport à la vidéo
consultation est ce que c'est une
une solution par rapport à aux problèmes
rencontrés dans les déserts médicaux
c'est une chose est sûre c'est une
solution mais c'est aussi une solution
riche c'est une solution qui a été de
mise été mise en place début de
l'épidémie dès le mois de mars qui a
rendu beaucoup de services à ce que
beaucoup de gens rechignent à se
déplacer dans les cabinets médicaux
par peur d'attraper le coc vide et qui
parce qu'on a me dis à tout le monde
surtout ne vous ne passez pas chercher
chez le médecin beaucoup de
consultations était transformée comme ça
c'est la solution
ça fait partie des solutions tout cas
merci jean luc le gall d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins du var aux pays-bas lé
couvre-feu doit être relevé je cite
immédiatement décision tout à l'heure du
tribunal de la haye qui estime l'urgence
particulière requise pour justifier une
telle mesure n'a pas été démontrée ce
couvre-feu était une première dans le
pays depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
les explications de maxime abers l'a mis
sous cloche est elle sur le point de
voler en éclat aux pays bas le tribunal
de la haye a ordonné la suspension pure
et simple du couvre-feu instauré
jusqu'au 2 mars
pour les juges le gouvernement a abusé
de ses pouvoirs et n'a pas respecté le
cadre légal ni le principe d' urgence
particulière
les juges ont considéré qu'il y avait
une pandémie que le virus mute et que la
pression était forte sur le système de
santé
c'est une période inquiétante toutes les
décisions sont compliquées et des
mesures aussi drastiques doivent être
prises dans le cadre de la loi auprès de
catherine conséquences de cette
annulation des centaines de néerlandais
pourrait réclamer l'annulation ou le
remboursement des amendes reçues pour
non respect du couvre-feu
parmi les habitants de la haye les
réactions sont mitigées
je pense qu'il est très important que le
juge ait conclu qu'il n'y a plus de
raison d'imposer le couvre feu donc tout
le monde est content j'ai vu sur
internet des gens explosé de joie parce
qu'il n'y a vraiment aucune raison
d'avoir un couvre feu
[Musique]
je pense que la décision appartient au
gouvernement et parce que c'est un
tribunal je ne vois pas le rapport
alors oui je pense que cela dépend plus
du gouvernement que du tribunal à
l'origine de la plante virus vareilles
de vérité sur le virus en néerlandais
un groupe opposé aux mesures de lutte
contre le coc vite 19 et pourfendeur du
couvre-feu
ce serait un peu étrange qu'une sorte de
petits groupes puissent déposer une
plainte et ensuite que celle ci soit
jugée recevable par les instances
judiciaires
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement a
commis une erreur dans le processus
d'instauration du couvre feu
donc c'est une situation vraiment
intéressant en ce moment
aux pays-bas le variant britannique se
propage de plus en plus et le nombre de
nouveaux cas augmente 25 1229 tests
positifs enregistrés ces derniers jours
contre 24 1668 la semaine précédente le
nombre de décès a aussi augmenté
face à la menace des nouveaux variants
le gouvernement néerlandais avait donc
annoncé début février sa décision de
prolonger le couvre feu national en
vigueur de 21h à 4h30 du matin
personnellement je comprends que
certaines personnes veuillent que le
couvre-feu disparaissent mais je penche
un peu du côté du gouvernement et avec
la circulation du variant britannique du
virus
je pense qu'il est préférable de faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour limiter la
propagation du virus
ce couvre feu le premier aux pays bas
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale a
donné lieu aux pires émeutes qu'a
connues le pays en plusieurs décennies
400 arrestations en un week-end après
des affrontements entre contestataires
et forces de l'ordre
wilhem engel fondateur du mouvement à
l'origine du procès s'est dit soulagé
satisfait de son côté le gouvernement a
décidé de contre attaquer le ministre de
la justice a ainsi annoncé la rédaction
d'une loi d'exception
objectif maintenir le couvre-feu en kit
amsterdam et la haye pour tel aviv où la
question du passeport vaccinale a fait
l'actualité
une mesure qui continue de faire débat à
travers le monde danemark grèce chypre
et israël optent pour ce précieux sésame
parions caudal avec serge abou et le 23
février prochain
il ferait elle entame une nouvelle étape
du déconfinement en cours
cette date devrait marquer la
réouverture des salles de sport mais
aussi des musées et autres lieux
culturels les restaurants hôtels et
salle de mariage pourront également
rouvrir le 9 mars prochain
si la situation sanitaire le permet la
condition obligatoire pour accéder à ces
lieux est simple l'obtention d'un
passeport vert
ce dimanche tel aviv et nicosie ont
signé un accord à ce sujet les citoyens
israéliens et chypriotes détenteurs de
ce passeport pourront voyager sans
restriction entre les deux pays
là tu me sèye permettez moi de vous dire
combien je suis heureux des récents
accords qui permettront la reprise des
vols et du tourisme entre israël et
chypre et nous appelons un plus grand
nombre de pays à adopter le passeport
vers un passeport vert sera attribuée à
toute personne vaccinée des informations
telles que la date du vaccin ou encore
celle de son expiration ils seront
mentionnés le gouvernement israélien
envisage d'étendre l'utilisation du
passeport vert dans les entreprises
l'objectif est clair inciter la
population à se faire vacciner comme l'a
indiqué le ministre israélien de la
santé
lully edelstein 44 % des israéliens ont
déjà reçu au moins une dose de vaccin
depuis le début de la campagne publiez
ce dimanche
une étude de la caisse
d'assurance-maladie israélienne montre
des résultats encourageants avec
notamment une baisse conséquente du taux
d'infection dans le pays et en direct de
tel-aviv à paula slayer journalistes
pour arte internationale c'est notre
rubrique
vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir pour l'asl ailleurs merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
44% de la population israélienne
vaccinés ou en tous les cas qui a reçu
une première injection comment est ce
que la population accueille cette
campagne vaccinale
parce que on voit qu'il ya des
réticences en france un dernier sondage
en date de début février 41 % de la
population française soit se faire
vacciner
déjà 44 % de la population donc israël
viennent à vacciner les israéliens
adhère s'est prêtée par de la campagne
deux cent mille personnes étaient
vaccinées par jour
aujourd'hui le la rapidité de la
vaccination ralenti dans moins de la
moitié de ces ombres et vaccinés par
jour
donc les personnes qui souhaitent être
vaccinés ont déjà été vaccinées et le
gouvernement dont maintenant traiter
avec les parties de la société qui sont
plus réticentes
c'est pourquoi le rythme a beaucoup
ralenti
cela inclut des membres des communautés
doute oui les arabes ainsi que des
communauté ultra-orthodoxe ultra
religieuses beaucoup de jeunes gens
refusent également de se faire vacciner
car il le considère pas être parti
demain vu de l'érable donc ce sont des
défis pour le gouvernement
le gouvernement va délivrer l'impasse
pas versé qui sera reçu par les gens
ayant reçu les deux doses de vaccin
pastor on ne pourra pas avoir accès aux
trajets internationaux
on ne pourra pas se rendre au
supermarché dans les donc c'est une
forme de pression du gouvernement afin
de pousser les gens de se faire vacciner
et le gouvernement facilite également la
vaccination
aujourd'hui par exemple la mea sharim
haineux communauté ultra orthodoxe de
jérusalem
m un nombre de centres de vaccination
mobile en tc a mené jusqu'au centre de
la communauté
ainsi les gens peuvent se faire vacciner
sur leur sol de la sur le seuil de leur
porte des ultra orthodoxes ont été
vaccinées aujourd'hui car il était si
aisé de se faire vacciner
il ya également des pressions de la part
du premier ministre benjamin netanyahu
qui a dit qu'un demi million de
personnes de plus de 50 n'avaient pas
été vaccinés et que si ces gens se
faisait vacciner alors on pourrait
sortir du confinement rapidement
donc ce sont des moyens de pression au
niveau du gouvernement
il soutient également un projet de loi
qui publierait les listes de personnes
non vaccinées pour les autorités ces
autorités auraient d'un sujet que la
tâche de les encourager à se faire
vacciner
donc le rythme baisse et le gouvernement
en fait pression pour que les personnes
qui ne sont pas encore certains ou qui
sont contre la vaccination se fasse
vacciner pour l'asl et d'ailleurs vous
avez évoqué le passeport vers ce fameux
passeport vaccinale c'est donc la
prochaine étape dans quel état d'esprit
est encore là la population face à ça
parce que ça fait débat en europe 1 même
si certains pays comme le danemark la
grèce ou encore chypre ont décidé de
l'adopter
l'idée d'un passeport vert j'ai parlé
avec des gens de toute la société et la
plupart de mes interlocuteurs pensent
réflexion est juste que les gens aient
le choix le choix en israël
c'est de devenir un passeport vert a dit
quand on a été vaccinée dès qu'ils ne
seraient pas vaccinés mais on peut
obtenir un geste gratuit qui est valable
pour 48 heures donc cela signifie que
sans vaccination il faut se faire
écouter une fois tous les deux jours
c'est une option pour ceux qui sont
contre la vaccination bien sûr c'est
beaucoup moins facile que de tenir à ce
temps fort vera qui permet de se rendre
dans les espaces publics
je souhaite cependant mentionné que le
gouvernement s'était livrera ses vaccins
vers une semaine après la seconde dose
et une ligne sur ce passeport explique
qu'il est valable que pour un sinois
cela montre que les parce que le
gouvernement n'est pas certain que
sais-je de vaccination et que ces deux
vaccins resteront efficace à terme sur
tous ces vaccins venant de pfizer plus
en plus tôt et personnes tout au moins
nous avons le choix nous avons cette
option ne sommes pas obligés d'être
vaccinés si l'on compare cela avec le
sentiment en europe il est certain que
le niveau du soutien bien plus élevée en
israël que par exemple dans plusieurs
états européens player vous venez de
souligner le fait que
peut-être il faudra se faire vacciner
plus tard c'est ce que londres également
a indiqué du coup dans quel état
d'esprit est la communauté scientifique
par rapport à cette campagne de
vaccination face aux variants notamment
quand on pense à la communauté
scientifique israélienne le corps
hospitalier est davantage d'israël c'est
un échange que la réception de stocks
importants de vaccins du buzzer mais je
donne aux entreprises pharmaceutiques
les informations qu'ils descendent et
cela soulage les questions de vie privée
mais à part mais hormis cela signifie
que les vaccins notamment le vaccin et
certains efficace contre le varia
britannique
c'est les variantes dominant le plus
dominant pour le moment en israël il ya
des inquiétudes concernant les variantes
sud africain et brésilien mais cours des
derniers jours il ya trois cas en israël
de quelle personne qui a reçu les deux
doses du vaccin ont été contaminées par
le sud-africain donc qu'il reste et tout
ton concernant l'efficacité du vaccin de
pfizer contre les variantes sud-africain
l'industrie médicale
israël est également inquiète concernant
invariants israélien qui pourrait être
résistant aux vaccins le problème c'est
que au fur et à mesure que les vaccins
sont dispensés jeu
virus évolue afin de bien outre ce
vaccin d'après les docteurs il est trop
tôt pour se prononcer mais on pourrait
se retrouver dans une situation il
faudrait recevoir chaque année un vaccin
contre le cornac russie tout comme on
reçoit chaque année un vaccin contre la
grippe surveillent la situation et c'est
pourquoi le confinement est toujours en
oeuvre exercice en israël le premier
ministre a déclaré que grâce basse pour
vers les personnes vaccinées pourraient
se rendre dans les cinémas des marchés
verts ou des biotech
mais pour la majorité des gens qui n'ont
pas reçu des doses de la vaccination
les doses du vaccin il se confie
demandera aucun l'effet du bic et est le
véritable conflit pourrait durer encore
deux semaines
cela dépend du taux d'efficacité du
vaccin notamment contre les variants sud
africains brésiliens
merci pour la star d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes que
vous êtes journaliste pour rt
international et on reste en israël avec
l'état hébreu qui refuse à l'entrée de
vaccins dans la bande de gaza motif
invoqué une décision politique le
gouvernement palestinien en appel à l'om
s et dénonce une violation du droit
international
florian lambert un espoir de
réconciliation moyen-orient déjà mis à
mal à l'occasion de la campagne de
vaccination
ce mardi le hamas mouvement palestinien
au pouvoir dans la bande de gaza a
dénoncé une violation criminelle du
droit international de la part d'israël
l'autorité palestinienne accuse en effet
l'état hébreu d'avoir bloqué l'entrée de
milliers de doses de vaccin pour lutter
contre le commis de 19 à gaza qui compte
près de 2 millions d'habitants
c'est une mesure discriminatoire
un vrai crime est une violation de
toutes les lois internationales et
normes humanitaires le hamas en appelle
à la fin du blocus israélien autour de
la bande de gaza séparée
géographiquement de la cisjordanie un
blocus qui dure depuis une décennie
qu israël justifie par la présence du
mouvement armé hamas
l'état hébreu là sur l'entrée de vaccins
à gaza est à l'étude
la demande palestinienne d'entrée de
vaccin est en cours d'examen et attend
une décision politique
depuis le lancement de sa campagne de
vaccination début février l'autorité
palestinienne indique avoir reçu deux
mille doses de la part d'israël et dix
mille doses du vaccin spoutnik v grâce à
une subvention du gouvernement russe
le gouvernement palestinien condamne le
blocage des vaccins destinés à sa
population et en appelle à l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé doit
tenir israël comme pleinement
responsable des dangers liés à
l'interdiction d'entrée des vaccins à
gaza dans la bande de gaza plus de
cinquante trois mille cas ont été
enregistrés depuis le début de la
pandémie et 538 personnes sont décédées
du côté de 19 de son côté le japon a
commencé aujourd'hui sa campagne
vaccinale prioritaires les
professionnels de santé
leila sarah les très attendus premières
doses seront administrés à partir de ce
mercredi à environ quarante mille
professionnels de la santé volontaires
médecins et infirmières de 100 hôpitaux
du japon sont concernés le gouvernement
a été très prudents et nous avons donc
décidé de faire les essais cliniques
avec des japonais pour montrer que nous
avons tout fait pour prouver l'innocuité
et l'efficacité du vaccin réservé dans
un premier temps un nombre réduit de
personnels hospitaliers la vaccination
seront ensuite élargies aux autres
professionnels de santé
elle ne sera pas étendue aux personnes
âgées avant avril au plus tôt le reste
de la population devant attendre
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
al'approche djo de tokyo je ne prends
pas vraiment en considération les jeux
olympiques
mon travail est de déployer le vaccin au
fur et à mesure que nous sommes
approvisionnés par l'europe
un feu vert réglementaire a été accordée
au vaccin de pfizer biotech
le japon a également conclu des accords
avec les laboratoires astrazeneca et
moderna afin d'obtenir suffisamment de
doses pour ses 126 millions d'habitants
c'était sur arte france dans quelques
instants la deuxième heure d'information
gros plan sur la guyane 4
k2 variant du coc u19 ont été détectés
le séquençage doit encore préciser de
quelle souche il s'agit et puis
parleront des stratégies différentes
adoptées par les pays face aux
coronavirus si la france semble avoir
choisi de vivre avec l'allemagne prêche
le zéro co vide l'europe peut-elle se
mettre au diapason
c'est toute la question a tout de suite
[Musique]
là
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais l'air
avec ne sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france il ya à peu près
un enfant sur deux en france qui est
soit victime soit hauteur de cyber
violence sur internet un contenu haineux
de quelqu'un qui dit à une fillette de 8
ans on va te suicider ça ça doit être
retirée immédiatement il n'ya aucun
débat à avoir sur son retrait là parce
que ça ça fait des suicides la loi le
condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit de
faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste que
les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est dans l'hymne
quel rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a
vu et big for donc les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet c'est quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux hanul à
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change l'équilibré
stratégique pour le moyen-orient après
50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette région
complexe preuve était le seul à pouvoir
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
grâce à ses relations différentes avec
tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran
tu n'iras les pays de la région et
réglera les relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france a
placé à une deuxième heure d'information
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi 16
février pour soul à von der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
appelle les états européens à rester
unis dans leur stratégie face au co vie
de 19 sur le terrain les stratégies elle
dit faire vivre avec le service com de
com en france d'un côté ou le choix du
zéro co vide comme en allemagne
de l'autre la france ne compte pas
réduire dans l'immédiat les effectifs de
l'opération militaire barkan
déclarations d' emmanuel macron ce matin
en visioconférence au sommet du g5 celle
le chef de l'état précise qu'un retrait
massif des forces françaises serait une
erreur il appelle à je cite décapiter
les groupes djihadistes affiliés à al
qaïda il exhorte les pays de la région
au sursaut politique
[Musique]
plus que jamais la confusion en birmanie
nouvelles inculpations ce matin
d'auxonne sotchi l'ex chef du
gouvernement est accusé d'avoir violé la
loi sur la gestion des catastrophes
naturelles
les protestations se poursuivent à
rangoun alors que l'ambassadeur chinois
dans le pays estime que la situation
actuelle n'est pas ce que pékin voudrait
voir
[Musique]
la direction tout de suite la guyane ou
quatre premiers cas de variants du
commis 19 ont été détectés une des
personnes contaminées est décédé la
semaine dernière les prélèvements vont
être soumis au séquençage pour connaître
avec certitude le type de la souche en
cause anglaise sud africaine ou
brésilienne à un procédé qui s'effectue
dans un délai de dix jours à l'institut
pasteur de paris où seuls quelques
dizaines d'échantillons ont été testés
est frontalière du brésil la guyane n'a
pas encore détecté le variant dit p1 de
manaus mais restent sur le qui-vive et
sous restriction on parle de la
situation à cayenne avec ivana ghoga
porte-parole du collectif mayouri santé
guyenne bonsoir il va nagua merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
les premiers cas de variants découvert
donc sur le territoire guyanais liés à
la proximité avec le brésil
quel est l'état d'esprit ambiant à
cayenne bien sûr la l'incertitude
l'inquiétude j'imagine non même pas en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ces
quatre variants sont rentrés sur le
territoire par l' aéroport en fait un
félix éboué
donc ils viennent tous les quatre de
paris et même pas du brésil pour le coup
parce que nous avons en fait à ce jour
encore des restrictions très importantes
sur le territoire on a une frontière à
l'intérieur du pays même dans la commune
de saint georges où justement fait en
est censé faire le filtre entre la
population qui pourrait arriver du
brésil et celles qui pourraient venir de
guyane et aller vers le brésil
donc on va dire que là où on s'attendait
que justement peut-être viendraient ces
variants du brésil quand ils viennent de
notre aéroport félix éboué de paris
alors qu'on est censé avoir des tests
pcr avant de prendre la viande pour la
guyane et qu'on est censé avoir aussi
une certaine
donc qu'est ce que vous dénoncez en
expliquant cela en fait aujourd'hui ce
qui nous pose problème c'est que la
population est empêché de circuler
depuis un an quand même pour ce qui est
du couvre-feu en guyane et que depuis c1
dans la new ce que nous pouvons
constater c'est que le virus fait sa vie
en fait il fait ses va-et-vient ça monte
ça descend tout en ayant un couvre-feu
qui n'a jamais cessé qui n'est jamais
parti alors pour justement faire face à
une un pic
parce qu'on a eu un pic en janvier qui
n'est pas la seconde bagarre pour nous
la population qui en fait un pic
parce que du coup on a eu vingt mille
départs en congés normal de fin d'année
puisque on a beaucoup de fonctionnaires
sur le territoire ou de personnes tout
court qui vont se balader et donc du
coup ces vingt mille la retour on les a
pas gérer et on a laissé le virus
rentrée sur notre territoire puisque à
ce moment là il n'y avait pas les tests
pcr exigé à l'entrée du territoire et
ensuite on nous dit que effectivement le
virus circule et en du coup on coupe
tout tout tout circulation à la
population anti l'économie guyanaise
depuis un an quand même depuis un an
nous les restaurateurs jamais eu non
vers un camp parfois jamais ils n'ont pu
ouvrir on va dire sur toute l'amplitude
possible sachant que c'est le soir que
se font beaucoup de que l'activité tout
est en fait en guyane on ne voit pas en
nous on ne se voit pas sortir de cette
crise alors que la crise elle fait ses
valets bien aujourd'hui on est en
dessous du seuil
dallaire il faut le savoir sur le nombre
de cas en guyane à peine une trentaine
par semaine et pourtant on est en
restriction majeure sans notre
territoire avec des contrôles partout
donc ils fonctionnent vraisemblablement
entre le brésil et la guyane
mais il ne fonctionne pas entre paris et
la guyane
et ça c'est bien dommage tous les cas
les variants sont donc rentrés s'ils ne
sont pas rentrés par le brésil comme
vous le dites mais par la métropole par
avion comment est-ce qu'il faut réagir
maintenant face à ces variants sachant
que le séquençage se fait d'ailleurs
d'or dans l'hexagone maintenant il faut
rapidement tracé
isolé tout à fait en fait le collectif
justement mayouri santé gueule demande
il a été créé dès avril
les premiers cas c'était en mars nous
avions cinq cas sur notre territoire et
on disait attention nous la guyane de
parts déjà la suffisance au niveau
sanitaire
on a à peine quinze lits de réanimation
qui se passe dans ceux qui se battent en
duel pour une population de 300 milles
estimé
donc derrière on disait attention et
aujourd'hui c'est pareil pour le variant
on sait qu'on a quatre cas de variants
on sait que potentiellement il ya des
cas contacts assez pariant donc il est
urgent d'identifier les personnes de les
isoler et d'éviter que justement cela se
propage dans la population puisque
vraisemblablement les verrous ont bien
pan de fonctionner au tour mais on voit
qu'en fait plutôt que de se donner les
moyens matériels et humains au niveau
sanitaire plus de docteur à moment donné
on nous avait annoncé 250 médecins qui
devrait renforcer les hôpitaux de guyane
en attend toujours
on nous avait demandé au nez on te le
dis que des lits de réanimation et des
lits d'hospitalisation viendrait en
attend toujours
aujourd'hui on parle aujourd'hui d'un
chu en guyane la guyenne quand même
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on l'a
découverte et c'est un territoire
français donc voilà aujourd'hui en fait
on se pose des questions parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus facile pour certains de
restreindre la circulation de la
population que de se doter en moyens
humains et matériels sanitaires pour
faire face à un virus que quand même
aujourd'hui depuis un an elle sur notre
territoire et qu'on devrait pouvoir
réussir à vivre avec en fait nous
voudrions vivent avec
vous avez évoqué les chiffres 15 lits
pour trois cent mille habitants en
guyane hormis la menace des variantes
quelle est la situation générale en
guyane quid de la pression hospitalière
notamment en ce moment même oui tout à
fait parce que on a quand même quand
même aujourd'hui l'hypertension les
problèmes vasculaires qui ont toujours
existé en guyane qu'on n'a jamais
réussir à résoudre on va dire en termes
d'accompagnement sanitaires on a
toujours avec nous le problème de
coriaces à dans nos maladies tropicales
avec les moustiques
donc derrière aujourd'hui on a des on
al'impression la dengue
je voulais parler de la dengue excusez
moi et donc du coup on a des maladies
qui d'ailleurs la dengue a les mêmes
symptômes que aujourd'hui le coc vite
quand même donc on se rend compte qu'on
ne nous parle plus de la dengue alors
qu'ils ont les mêmes symptômes et que du
coup en fait voilà il y là une question
à se poser est la vraie question c'est
quand est les moyens vous rappeler à
l'époque j'étais intervenu parce qu'on
avait demandé un hôpital de campagne en
avait on avait un pic où il y avait une
trentaine de personnes en réanimation
est aujourd'hui bon c'est permis ces
moyens-là son parti ils sont partis
alors qu' on doit soit on doit soit
disant faire face à une guerre qu'on
répondre à ma question
tiens et elle en soi même en guyane bah
justement pour l'instant l'hôpital tiens
on tient le les hôpitaux de chaînes ne
tienne comment dire ça tienne le coup
mais on n'est pas prêt face à un pic en
fait on est prêt pour faire face à
aujourd'hui aucune affluence
et heureusement que derrière comme je
vous le disais la pression est
redescendue côté qu'ovide il ya moins de
cas et même les cas d'hospitalisation
finalement ne restait pas longtemps et
ne faisait pas non plus des normes cas
de réanimation ni deux ni des normes cas
de décès heureusement mais derrière
aujourd'hui si on doit faire face
invariants brésiliens ou que sais-je
on n'est pas prêt il n'y a pas ce qu'il
faut sur les territoires en moyens
humains et techniques
merci van huan avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes la
porte parole du collectif améliorer son
thé guyane la guyane méfiance donc face
aux variants tout comme l'europe qui
adoptent des stratégies opposées selon
les pays
après avoir fermé ce week-end ses
frontières avec la république tchèque et
le tyrol autrichien l'allemagne pourrait
en faire de même avec la moselle
française la décision de berlin va à
l'encontre des règles de l'espace
schengen mais entre
tout faire pour vaincre le comique 19 et
vivre avec le virus
les allemands semblent avoir choisi leur
voix emily cook h
un couvre-feu à 18 heures mais pas de
confinement des écoles des frontières
ouvertes et une pandémie qui continue de
faire partie du quotidien des français
avec en plus l'arrivée de nouveaux
variants mais pour le gouvernement
même si le virus est toujours actif la
situation est maîtrisée et ne nécessite
pas plus de restrictions notre situation
je la qualifierais donc par deux mots
maîtrisé par rapport à ce que l'on
observe chez nos voisins mais fragile
car le virus circule encore activement
sur notre territoire est d'autant plus
fragile avec l'élément nouveau que
constitue l'émergence de nouvelles
souches plus contagieuse due à cet
aspect situation maîtrisée les fragiles
également considéré meilleur élève que
ses voisins de l'union européenne et
malgré un recul des contaminations
berlin a décidé de prendre les devants
face à une hausse des nouveaux cas chez
certains de ses voisins
résultat les arrivées depuis la
république tchèque et le tyrol
autrichien se font au compte-gouttes un
test pcr négative doit être présentée
afin de pouvoir rentrer sur le
territoire
une décision qui ne va pas dans le sens
de bruxelles qui défend la libre
circulation instauré par l'espace
schengen je peux comprendre la peur face
aux mutations du coronavirus mais il
faut dire la vérité qui est que le virus
ne se laissera pas arrêté par des
frontières fermées
la seule chose qui est ce sont les
vaccins et les mesures de précaution
sanitaires
il est à mon avis erronée de revenir
comme en mars 2020 à une europe ayant
des frontières fermées
une déclaration qui ne passe pas en
allemagne d'autant plus que vers l'un
reproche à bruxelles la lenteur de la
campagne de vaccination
maintenant ça suffit la commission
européenne a commis assez d'erreurs lors
de la commande de vaccins au cours des
derniers mois hors union européenne
d'autres pays ont également choisi de ne
pas lésiner sur les restrictions
sanitaires pour endiguer la pandémie et
éviter la propagation des nouveaux
variants sur leurs élites
à auckland en nouvelle-zélande après que
trois personnes ont été dépistées
positives au kobus 19 dont deux aux
variants britannique
ce lundi la mairie de la ville la plus
peuplée du pays a décidé de confiner ces
habitants pour trois jours cette méthode
de confinement rapide a également été
adoptée par l'australie la chine taïwan
ou encore le vietnam
une stratégie qui vise à réduire à zéro
la circulation du virus
de nombreux spécialistes plaident pour
qu'elle soit aussi appliquée en europe
alors entre vivre avec le virus et le
zéro qu'ovide quelle stratégie est la
plus efficace laquelle est encore
applicable ou acceptable par la
population les stratégies sont elles
compatibles à l'échelle européenne c'est
le décryptage
[Musique]
et nous invitait à françois krakowski
médecin spécialiste en santé publique et
pascal crépey épidémiologistes
enseignant chercheur à l'école des
hautes études en santé publique bonsoir
messieurs merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france françois
krakowski
la chef de la commission européenne pour
cela von der leyen appelle les états de
lieux à rester unis dans leur stratégie
face aux comètes 19 doux rêve ou réalité
plausible elle était plausible pense en
tout cas il faut un minimum de bonne
volonté de tous les états je ne pense
pas qu'il faille que l'individualisme et
le nationalisme soit ddd les meilleures
solutions face à ces une telle crise il
faut que tout le monde agisse de concert
mais je pense aussi qu'il faut que
l'union européenne quelque part se met
au niveau de l'europe et qu'elle est
qu'elle fasse pas non plus ni évidemment
d'ingérence mais qu'elle ne fasse pas de
de consigne qu'ils soient trop général
parce que je pense que chaque pays a
aussi une façon de une façon de réagir
une façon de faire et des consignes trop
globale pourrait aussi être pénalisant
donc il faut faire front ensemble au
sein de l'union européenne et je pense
que qu'il ya des armes en fait qu'il dit
des options des choses qui peuvent être
faites au niveau de l'europe notamment
en termes de négociations alors il ya eu
des il ya des ailes et des
questionnements sur les commandes de
vaccins mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même des éléments qui sont qui
permettent aux pays de l'union
européenne d'accéder plus facilement
avec 5 d'autres pays
et si on était chaque pays individuels
c'est pas sûr qu'on aurait eu autant
accès aux vaccins non qui je pense qu'il
faut quand même une approche globale
européenne qu'on se reste soudée mais
ensuite il faut laisser des marges de
manoeuvre quand même à chaque pays pour
pouvoir adapter ses stratégies et ses
politiques de santé en termes de
prévention et de précaution face au
virus
parce qu'elle crée père avant de me
tourner vers vous envoyer ce qui a
déclaré emmanuel macron
au journal du dimanche nous sommes
désormais engagés dans une lutte contre
les variants qui est une véritable
course contre la montre sans une action
collective internationale rapide
efficace et solidaire
nous prenons le risque que le virus nous
échappe pascal crespin les mentalités
les responsabilités des français sont
différentes de celles des allemands et
des néerlandais qui doivent arrêter un
d'ailleurs leur couvre-feu sur décision
de justice sont différentes des italiens
des espagnols des portugais
comment trouver le juste milieu entre
vivre avec le virus et le zéro qu'ovide
le zéro que vides ça doit être un
objectif et je pense que c'est un
objectif général pour chaque pays du
monde entier
après la question c'est à quelle
échéance est ce qu'on pourrait arriver
et par quels moyens est ce qu'on peut
arriver à cet objectif de zéro co bid et
là effectivement les moyens vont être
différent en fonction de la capacité des
différents états à travers le monde de
mettre en place et de et d'obtenir
l'acceptation de la population des soit
des mesures très restrictive de
confinement très fort potentiellement
jugé insupportable en france par exemple
soit d'autres moyens tels que la
vaccination à condition que celle ci ait
suffisamment vite pour ne pas être
rattrapé par d'éventuels
émergence de variants qui combattirent
la drogue ou serait de toute façon
l'échéance et c'est peut-être au final
un juste milieu entre entre à la fois
s'appuyer sur des mesures contraignantes
de limitation de la diffusion du virus
et puis des outils tels que tels que la
vaccination qui vont nous permettre de
finir de traverser cette crise sanitaire
majeure est d'arriver à un monde post
coït 19 françois krakowski vivre avec le
coronavirus ça veut dire quoi au final
parce que finalement on vit bien avec
les morts du cancer guide bien avec le
sida également pour bien vivre avec le
sida
je veux que tout le monde soit avec toi
je voulais dire évidemment mais je veux
dire qu'il ya des maladies qui sont
autour de nous et on vit sans
confinement malgré toutes les maladies
il ya eu il ya eu des gros progrès en
ferme en fête à en termes de prise en
charge du sida tout à fait il ya des des
virus au jour un autre exemple serait la
grille pain avec laquelle on vit on vit
tous les ans et est finalement
l'objectif est plutôt de baisser la
mortalité ou les morbidité qui sont
associés au virus de la grippe chaque
année via notamment des vaccinations
annuel mais aussi maintenant on a
découvert toutes les mesures barrières
qui peuvent aussi aider sur ce type
d'infection donc ça pourrait vouloir
dire ça à vivre avec le virus c'est
finalement un virus que vous pourrez
attraper mesures barrières ça veut dire
que à terme quand
si on arrive à voir le bout de
de cette pandémie commis 19 dire que
vous appelez à continuer à vivre avec
les masques pour éviter d'avoir la
grippe on va plus se faire la bise se
serrer la main
bon on pourra faire quand même un petit
peu plus soft mais met par exemple on
sait les masques protège surtout des
personnes qui sont malades
si cette épidémie permet de de ne plus
de choquer ou de prendre l'habitude de
porter un masque lorsqu'on a la grille
pour une gastro-entérite ou autre il n'y
a pas que les masques juste se laver les
mains beaucoup plus souvent l'hiver
quand il ya toutes ces épidémies
on éviterait beaucoup de maladies et
aussi beaucoup de marins puisque la
grippe c'est que l'ama nombre de morts
assez élevé chaque année mais pour
revenir au co vite 19 vivre avec le
virus pourrait être limité le donc je
disais le nombre de décès ou de de
mortalité cv de morbidité pardon sévère
c'est à dire des symptômes qui sont qui
son handicap en pénalisant et donc de
protéger finalement les plus vulnérables
et finalement voir se dire que c'est un
virus qui circulent mais qui sera
peut-être avec des symptômes qui seront
similaires à la grippe ou à des rhumes
un peu un peu sévère ça peut peut-être
vouloir dire ça à vivre avec avec le
virus arras que c'est souhaitable je ne
sais pas en tout cas l'objectif reste le
nombre de décès c'est ça qu'on souhaite
éviter surtout les personnes qu'ils
attrapent est qui et qui sans soigne au
bout cinq jours finalement le nombre de
cas ce sera forcément ce qui est le plus
important ce qui est important c'est les
personnes qui vont réanimation qui vont
présenter des symptômes graves
respiratoires ou cardiaques et
évidemment ceux qui vont décéder
et c'est ça qu'on essaie d'éviter et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que la
stratégie vaccinale en france cible en
priorité les personnes qui sont
identifiés comme les plus à risque de
décès ou de comorbidité sévères afin
justement de diminuer ce taux de
mortalité est de
et de maladies graves qui sont la
conséquence grave parce qu'elle crée
paix l'allemagne menace de fermer ses
frontières avec la moselle où la
circulation des variants inquiète
regarder la déclaration de la sous
préfecture de la moselle
il n'est pas question de fermer les
frontières je pense que ce serait un
préjudice pour tout le monde
on sait aussi qu'une partie des services
hospitaliers de nos voisins sont armés
par des médecins ou des personnels
français ce serait évidemment très
embêtant si on fermer les frontières
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas d'actualité
allemagne qui souhaite donc a priori le
zéro co vide pourrait fermer les
frontières avec la moselle les virus
pourtant n'ont pas de passeport et ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières
certes mais je pense que dans cette
épidémie il faut arrêter en fait de
raisonner en cas d'état il faut vraiment
raisonner en termes de territoire et de
presque deux zones sanitaires et est en
fait donc que leur il fallait confiner
la moselle il aurait fallu amont à mon
sens prendre des mesures certainement
plus forte de confinement ou autres pour
essayer de contrôler la dynamique de
propagation du variant alors on sait pas
si c'est le sud africain au brésilien
mais enfin tout cas l'un des deux de ces
variants sur sur le territoire est en
tout cas ralentir ralentir sa diffusion
et ralentir son expansion bien
évidemment et ça il faut essayer de
faire comprendre ça aux gens on ne peut
pas rendre hermétique un territoire et
on ne va pas pouvoir empêcher que le
variant sud africain au brésilien qui
circulent en moselle mais qui circule
d'ailleurs ailleurs ce territoire mais
en tout cas qui circulent fortement en
moselle ne se répandent au delà de la
moselle
néanmoins on peut essayer de ralentir
cette propagation et ainsi éviter que la
moselle ne devienne le nouveau
supercluster tel que celui qu'on a vu à
mulhouse l'an dernier au début de
l'épidémie qui avait enflammé tout l'est
de la france et donner une dynamique
très forte très brutal aller à
l'épidémie donc moi personnellement je
pense que c'est une erreur de ne pas
avoir renforcé s'est enfin les mesures
et je comprends totalement la réaction
de l'allemagne parce que encore une fois
il faut pas se dire que
le fait que des pays différents prennent
des mesures différentes est une preuve
de des terreaux gênés it et des réponses
en fait il faut que les réponses soient
adaptées aux situations sanitaires des
pays et donc on peut avoir une
une uniformité en fait de réponse en
terme de règles et de moyens mais que
ses règles et ses moyens et bien soit
appliquée en fonction de la situation
sanitaire des des régions des länder où
des départements français et qu'avec
ainsi nous ayons une approche la plus
adaptée possible et la plus la plus
juste la plus fine en fonction de la
dynamique de l'épidémie
messieurs on a parlé de la france et
d'allemagne qui ont des stratégies
différentes
je vous propose de regarder ce qu'a dit
le professeur flahault le directeur de
l'institut de santé globale de
l'université de genève sur le plan
sanitaire l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande sont les champions du
monde incontesté pour le faible nombre
de décès par habitant et sur le plan
social
la vie a repris ses droits bars
restaurants activités culturelles et
sportives et que les universités sont
normalement ouverts les gestes barrière
quasi inexistant françois krakowski
alors évidemment on gère pas un pays de
5 millions d'habitants comme on gère une
nation 66 millions de citoyens et aussi
la dimension insulaire je vous la corde
mais on peut pas trouver des solutions
comme canberra et wellington on l'a vu à
melbourne a confiné cinq jours pour un
seul cas de variantes détecter ces très
drastiques
c'est hyper intéressant que mesurée ça
rejoint ce que disait monsieur crêpés
c'est à dire que finalement c'est des
mesures qui sont très ciblées mais si on
détecte un cas ou deux et finalement on
confine là on l'a détecté pour éviter
que ça se répand de façon très stricte
et de fait c'est très efficace
simplement je
je rappelle cela va peut-être à
l'encontre de ce que dit le président
emmanuel macron il dit qu'il faut agir
de manière générale rapide tous ensemble
et vous vous dites qu'il faut agir de
manière ciblée donc du coup qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
je pense qu'il fallait agir de manière
ciblée aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un
petit peu différent on peut encore agir
relativement de façon ciblée
si on détecte des variants je pense
c'est ça le propos de monsieur crêpés
mais ce qu'on a essayé de faire cette
mesure ces mesures ciblées c'était si je
me souviens bien la fin de l'été on
avait des mesures régionales et pendant
l'été même ailleurs
et en fait on a bien vu les territoires
qui étaient concernés ont été vendus
bout en disant hors de question que nous
on ferme nos restaurants et nous et nos
activités
alors que dans département d'à côté tout
fonctionne normalement donc en fait moi
je remets pas ça en cause un puisque je
comprends tout à fait sûr les
restaurateurs ou autre et qui sont dès
aujourd'hui que je ce que je soutiens
exemple évidemment parce que ils ont
énormément de difficultés mais c'est
simplement on a essayé de le faire je
pense que ça n'a pas fonctionné on était
peut-être après en france à faire ces
concessions de façon très violente très
rapide et assez brutal
c'est quand même ce que vous l'avez vu
en nouvelle zélande s'est ébruitée alors
tout est fermé blocage complet sur sur
une grande ville du jour au lendemain
c'est quand même assez brutale donc
voilà je pense qu'on n'était pas prêts
donc aujourd'hui c'est simplement une
adaptation de se dire on n'est pas plus
près qu'avant donc on comprend des
mesures plus générales
je pense que c'est ça un peu l'idée
après je pense qu'en termes d'efficacité
et à la fois sur le plan économique mais
je pense aussi sur plan sanitaire pas
uniquement sur le co vide mais
psychologique
peut-être aurait-on quand même intérêts
peut-être à pour donner des perspectives
également à faire un confinement qui
soit assez stricte mais qui soit sur une
durée très limitée et au monde disent au
moins un revenu de visibilité
la semaine l'appel notamment de françois
grosdidier le maire de l'est républicain
de de metz qui a proposé cette mesure
merci françois grond fier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin spécialiste en santé
publique merci également à vous parce
qu'elle crée paix d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que vous êtes
épidémiologistes enseignant chercheur à
l'école des hautes études en santé
publique
restez sur arte france dans quelques
instants le sommet du g5 c'est la france
ne compte pas réduire dans l'immédiat
les effectifs de l'opération militaire
barkan déclarations des manuels japon ce
matin puis focus sur la birmanie
nouvelles inculpations ce matin
d'auxonne sotchi l'ex chef du
gouvernement est accusé d'avoir violé la
loi sur la gestion des catastrophes
naturelles
[Musique]
fin janvier des petits investisseurs
sont parvenus à se coordonner sur
internet pour faire plier de grands
fonds d'investissement rassurez-vous
vous avez quelqu'un qui en ont bien
profité qui ont mis à genoux un iphone
mais comme comme on faisait déjà depuis
je vous dis 30 ans on la seule
différence est l'effet de foule s'est
organisée sur des réseaux sociaux donc
c'est un peu la version 3.0 des
opérations organisées entre
investisseurs ne faut pas considérer ça
comme la révolution des petits contre
les gros et c'est non cdti beaucoup plus
malins qui sont des grosses mains et qui
ont organisé leur coup on nous vend un
peu le conte de fées que c'est que des
sardines qui ont attaqué le requin est
en fait je pense que parmi les sardines
y avait aussi des ruptures
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que que la france a été
plus mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes
et étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir mais comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe ron était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs le
problème est maintenant de voir comment
joe biden va traiter un sujet s'il
relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de la colle 8 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france il est 21h30
heure française d'info continue
la france ne compte pas réduire dans les
médias ses effectifs de l'opération
militaire barkan déclarations d'
emmanuel macron ce matin en
visioconférence au sommet du g5 sahel au
coeur des échanges le point sur la lutte
anti jihadistes dans la région sur le
locataire de l'elysée un retrait massif
des forces françaises serait une erreur
il appelle à décapiter les groupes
djihadistes affiliés à al-qaïda et
exhorte les pays de la région où sursaut
politique ainsi qu'à un retour de l'état
dans les territoires délaissés
françois xavier lambert la mobilisation
nationale en faveur du accentuer la
pression sur les groupes djihadistes
présent dans les pays sahéliens c'est
l'un des principaux messages adressés
par emmanuel macron à ses homologues du
g5 sahel en compagnie des dirigeants du
mali du burkina faso du niger de la
mauritanie et du tchad
le président français a dressé un bilan
des actions menées depuis le précédent
sommet il ya un an un bilan toujours
très mitigé malgré quelques réussites
des centaines de jihadistes ont
notamment été tuées dont abdelmalek
droukdal qui diriger al-qaïda au maghreb
islamique a battu en juin 2020 mais pour
la france le prix à payer est conséquent
cinquante sept soldats français ont péri
dans cette lutte en huit ans pour
emmanuel macron il faut désormais une
action renforcée pour affaiblir
durablement les groupuscules liés à al
qaïda et au groupe etat islamique
le premier message c'est une énigme ne
vont pas relâcher la pression sur les
groupes terroristes poursuivre à
l'emprise sur les trois frontières avec
en particulier l'apport du bataillon de
chiens mais menés dès les prochains
jours et prochaines semaines des
opérations concrètes dans cette zone
pour retrouver le contrôle
et là dessus nous ré engageons nos
forces pour véritablement essayer
d'aller décapité ses organisations avec
une action renforcée après avoir discuté
avec ses homologues africains le
président français s'est également
adressé aux journalistes depuis une
autre salle de l'élite
c'est emmanuel macron en a profité pour
rassurer ses partenaires la france ne
réduira pas à court terme ses effectifs
dans le sahel qui se compose de cinq
mille cent soldats 2020 a porté ses
fruits a permis des victoires qui était
attendu et nous avons obtenu les
résultats qui étaient les nôtres et donc
à l'aune de ces résultats d'une part du
réengagement conséquent du mali du
burkina faso du niger à la fois sur les
sujets militaires et sur les sujets de
retour de l'état d'une politique de
développement
je considère que précipiter un retrait
français en tout cas volonté de retirer
massivement les hommes ce qui est un des
schémas que j'ai étudié serait une
erreur le président français qui a aussi
salué la décision du président tchadien
d'envoyer 1200 hommes dans la zone dite
des 'trois frontière entre le mali le
niger et le burkina faso
emmanuel macron a aussi insisté sur la
nécessité de ne pas se contenter du
volet militaire est de donner une
perspective aux populations du sahel en
investissant dans ces territoires
délaissés de bonnes intentions qui
doivent encore se confirmer dans les
faits selon le chef de l'état le g5 ça
elle devrait se réunir avant l'été pour
faire le point sur la situation
intervention également tout à l'heure
par vidéo du secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken
il exprime le soutien des états unis au
g5 sahel alors que des chais les
affiliés d'al qaïda cherche à étendre
leur emprise en afrique
les états unis continueront à travailler
de près avec leurs partenaires africains
nous nous appuierons sur les efforts
existants dans l'ouest de l'afrique et
partagerons nos expériences acquises
dans le combat global contre
l'extrémisme violent et en direct du
tchad dans cette édition pour parler du
sahel rémois jean ati anthropologue
chercheur principal à l'institut
d'études de sécurité
bonsoir aime à dire une ati merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
paris temporise finalement sur le
retrait des soldats français engagés au
sel paris qui avait pourtant envisagé un
ce retrait n'est encore quelques
semaines pour pour le début d'année
qu'est ce qui selon vous a fait
infléchir la position d' emmanuel macron
ce qu'il faut d'abord préciser que la
position initiale
tel qu'annoncé avant cette conférence ce
sommet de dia mais n'a ce n'était pas un
retrait total
c'était un réajustement qui avaient été
annoncées notamment le rappel éventuel
des 500 derniers éléments si l'an
dernier les morts décidé après pau et je
pense que après discussion avec les
homologues mais aussi constatations des
résultats très mitigés sur le terrain
mais notamment aussi certainement de
l'impréparation de la force d'un coup
bas qui devrait prendre la relève d'un
côté et aussi l'incapacité dont des
armées nationales et de la force
conjointe a valablement remplacer
en fait ces éléments ont dû décider donc
en faveur d'un maintien pour le moment
de l'ensemble de la force barkan sur le
terrain vous venez de mentionner la
force d'un coup pensé que c'est la force
européenne la france est pleinement
engagée au sahel mais quid de l'europe
et justement je pense que depuis un
moment déjà la france en fait un artiste
sur la nécessité d'un engagement un plus
grand des autres partis qui ne se
limitent pas leurs optiques fera donc de
la france et de l'europe et je pense
qu'en ce moment la force d'un coup bas
est en train de se mettre en place donc
un progressivement avec l'engagement des
autres pays européens au sein de cette
force est la mission de cette force
faut-il le rappeler c'est un ajustement
d'accompagner en fait l'armée malienne
sur le terrain au combat mais aussi dans
la réoccupation et à la réinstallation
de l'état donc dans certaines zones
aujourd'hui aux mains des djihadistes
lundi que l'état était délaissé
le chef de l'état français qui a promis
une action renforcée pour essayer
d'aller décapité sur lancers mots les
organisations terroristes pourquoi un
tel langage guerrier mais je pense que
il y a eu beaucoup de discussions et des
débats autour en fait de la présence
même de barques peintes sur le terrain
beaucoup de mécontentement manifesté
aussi bien que dans celle de liaison
avec avec n'djamena je vais me permettre
de vous reposer cette question pourquoi
un tel langage guerrier de la part d'
emmanuel macron qui appelle à décapiter
les organisations terroristes si on a
retrouvé la liaison je pose si un
conflit qui est compliqué de vous
entendre on imagine haïti on va passer à
autre chose si on arrive à à rétablir la
connexion d'ici là on repassera vous
voir bien évidemment du côté de jaden
djamena merci en tous les cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
nouvelle journée de manifestations en
birmanie quinze jours après la prise par
la force du pouvoir par l'armée la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas malgré la
répression militaire
de son côté la dirigeante déchu san suu
kyi a été inculpé pour une deuxième
affaire ce mardi quand un voeckler
renversé le 1er février dernier
aung san suu kyi est depuis assigné à
résidence dans un lieu tenu secret ce
mardi les militaires au pouvoir ont tenu
à rassurer le monde entier sur l'état de
santé de l'ancien président de facto
mais gardons dow jones uci et you win
min dans un endroit plus sûr pour leur
sécurité
ils sont en bonne santé ce n'est pas
comme s'il n'avait été arrêté ils sont
logés chez eux
nous allons continuer à nous conformer à
la loi
nous allons procéder conformément à la
loi
je tiens à dire que nous n'irons pas au
delà de la loi
poursuivi pour avoir importé
illégalement des talkie walkie
hobson souci était de nouveau convoquée
au tribunal ce mardi l'ex dirigeante de
75 ans a été mise en examen pour un
nouveau chef d'inculpation
une nouvelle audience aura lieu le 1er
mars
hanks en sushi est poursuivi pour un
nouveau dossier
elle a été inculpée en application de la
sous section 8 de la loi sur les
exportations et les importations et
aussi de la section 25 de la loi sur la
gestion des catastrophes naturelles
mobilisés et déterminés les birmans
continuent quant à eux de manifester
dans tout le pays a rangoon des moines
bouddhistes se revendiquant de la
révolution du safran de 2007 ont défilé
devant la représentation locale des
nations unies dans la capitale naypyidaw
des birmans se sont réunis devant le
tribunal pour appeler à la libération
d'aung san suu kyi
nous ne voulons pas d'une dictature
militaire nous devrons donc nous battre
contre eux jusqu'à ce qu'il démissionne
cela fait longtemps que nous ne voulions
pas de jantes nous ainsi que nos parents
avons beaucoup souffert à cause d'eux
nous ne voulons pas d'eux si nous
voulons qu en dessous çi soit libéré
c'est parce qu'elle est une dirigeante
de notre pays
elle traite tout le monde équitablement
elle soutient le bon camp c'est une mère
pour tout le pays
dans le même temps la répression
militaire grandit dans le pays
les tanks sont de sortie et l'armée
recours à des tirs de balles en
caoutchouc et à balles réelles contre
les protestataires
d'importantes coupures d'internet ont
été signalées pour la deuxième nuit
consécutive l'armée birmane nie toute
implication de pékin dans ces
interruptions du réseau internet
l'ambassadeur chinois a de son côté
déclaré que la situation en birmanie
n'est pas je cite ce que la chine
voudrait voir et on repart du côté
jemina au tchad pour rétablir la liaison
avec ahmad jannati chercheur principal
l'institut d'études de sécurité réagir
en été on était en train de d'évoquer la
rhétorique guerrière d' emmanuel macron
pourquoi selon vous des mots comme
décapité par exemple employé par le
locataire de l'elysée je vous le disais
justement le sauver de djamena est
arrivé dans un contexte particulier
c'est un contexte où il y à une fronde
en fait aussi bien un hexagone que dans
le ciel devant l'engagement militaire de
la france au sahel et il était donc
nécessaire pour le président macron pour
justifier le maintien la continuation de
cette opération d'utiliser ces langages
très fort qui expliquerait si vous
voulez en termes de retours hic la
nécessité de répondre de manière très
forte à des ennemis qui sur le terrain
j'espère continuer de signer la mort des
macros a insisté aussi sur les dégâts
que ces groupes font sur le terrain
aussi bien sur les civils il a insisté
aussi sur les pertes côté français
donc je pense que derrière cette retirer
cette rhétorique il y à la nécessité
pour le président français d'expliquer
un contexte qui nécessite une présence
forte de la france et une présence
régulière devant l'ennemi qui fait des
dégâts aussi bien sur les amener du
design et du sahel que les communautés
aussi l'armée française une cinquantaine
de soldats morts en huit ans du côté du
du sel
emmanuel macron qui a exhorté les
dirigeants des cinq pays du sahel on
rappelle ans et malini
hier tchad mauritanie burkina faso il
les exhorte à un sursaut politique
il souhaite travailler avec nos
partenaires pour une évolution de notre
présent ce sont ses mots
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
sous-entend escape à un jeu à
d'équilibriste également de la part d'
emmanuel macron entre rester sur le
terrain mais en même temps essayer de
dire au pays sur place maintenant à
bientôt ça va être à vous de devoir
gérer tout ça oui je pense que yahia jeu
très claires d'équilibriste et qui une
fois de plus auront d'abord à cette
nécessité de rassurer l'opinion
mais d'un côté la france un appel depuis
un moment déjà
depuis en fait la conférence de
nouakchott et depuis pau à la nécessité
d'un engagement plus grands d'autres
partenaires et d'abord aux partenaires
ensuite aux partenaires à autre que le
pays est aujourd'hui je pense que le la
france souhaite même une intervention
plus grande des nations unies sur ce
dossier donc ça veut dire pour le
président pour le président ma course
il a une importance capitale et pas de
faire intervenir d'autres partenaires
sur ce aussi le cas la france semble
s'enliser et qui est justement provoque
cette fronde a décrit au public
ce sont les aléas du direct évidemment
il ya pas de problème on va dire oui
nati si vous me permettez après je vais
vous libérer une dernière question sur
le rôle des états unis il ya eu un
message dans tony blinken le nouveau
secrétaire d'état américain le chef de
la diplomatie
outre atlantique il a exprimé un soutien
vis-à-vis de la france et des pays du g5
sahel a
comment est ce que vous vous l'expliquer
on merci merci orange est un métier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions les
aléas du direct évidemment par par
visioconférence parfois c'est compliqué
je rappelle que rama jerry n'étiez donc
et anthropologue et chercheur principal
à l'institut d'études et de sécurité on
le remercie alexeï navalni de nouveau
devant la justice russe ce matin à
l'opposant politique jugé pour
diffamation envers un ancien combattant
la correspondance à moscou signée
antonio troisième journée d'audience
dans ce procès pour diffamation intentée
contre alexeï navalni et toujours pas de
verdict l'audience s'est terminée avec
le réquisitoire du procureur qui a
demandé une amende de 950 mille roubles
soit un peu plus de 10000 euros
et vu que l'opposant russe était sous le
coup d'une peine de prison avec sursis
au moment des faits le parquet demande
également que cette peine soit effectuée
il s'agit de la peine de trois ans et
demi de prison avec sursis qui a déjà
été convertis en peine de prison ferme
il y a deux semaines par un autre
tribunal donc au final une seule peine
pour les deux affaires
aujourd'hui le procureur a demandé de
prendre en compte la peine dans son
ensemble en pause et parly 2 décision du
tribunal
celle qui n'est pas encore exécutoire et
celle qui sera prononcée en même temps
elle demande d'imposer en tout cas une
pénalité de neuf cent cinquante mille
roubles à alexei dans le cadre de cette
affaire
l'audience d'aujourd'hui concernait une
plainte en diffamation contre alexeï
navalni il est en effet accusé d'avoir
insulté un ancien combattant qui
apparaissait dans une vidéo en faveur de
la réforme constitutionnelle adoptée
l'été dernier lors d'un vote populaire
et en russie les vétérans de la seconde
guerre mondiale jouissent d'un très
grand respect
après le réquisitoire du procureur le
verdict a été renvoyée au 20 février
rendez vous donc samedi pour suivre la
suite du marathon judiciaire auquel est
confronté alexeï navalni tensions
diplomatiques entre les taliban et
l'otan l'alliance atlantique annonce
qu'elle quittera l'afghanistan
venue alors que les attaques des
insurgés sont toujours quasi
quotidiennes les talibans demandent de
leur côté à un retrait total des soldats
étrangers mais calendrier restent floues
françois xavier lambert c'est une
décision qui aura de profondes
conséquences pour la sécurité du peuple
afghan
l'otan doit se prononcer prochainement
sur le maintien ou non de ces dix mille
soldats présents en afghanistan la
plupart sont affectés à la mission de
formation des forces de sécurité
afghanes une discussion entre les 30
pays membres aura lieu ce jeudi à ce
sujet même si aucune annonce n'est
prévue à l'issue de cette réunion le
secrétaire général de l'alliance a
toutefois précisé que l'organisation
militaire ne se retirera que lorsque les
conditions seront réunies
notre objectif commun est clair
l'afghanistan ne doit plus jamais servir
de refuge aux terroristes qui s'attaque
à nos pays
notre présence repose donc sur certaines
conditions des pistes bien qu'aucun des
alliés ne soit traité en afghanistan
plus longtemps que nécessaire
nous ne partirons qu'une fois le moment
venu jens stoltenberg a directement
accusé les talibans de ne pas respecter
leurs engagements et de poursuivre leurs
attaques contre les forces afghanes et
alliées une réponse à la mise en garde
est insurgé émis ce week-end ces
derniers menacent l'otan de poursuivre
la guerre si l'organisation ne quitte
pas l'afghanistan
notre message en vue de la réunion des
ministres de l'otan et que prolonger
l'occupation et la guerre n'est ni dans
votre intérêt ni dans celui de vos
peuples ou d'une autre
quiconque cherche à prolonger la guerre
et l'occupation sera tenu responsable
comme au cours des deux dernières
décennies ces nouvelles menaces
surviennent malgré un accord conclu avec
les talibans par l'ancien président
américain en février 2020 washington et
les insurgés se sont rencontrés à doha
pour évoquer le retrait total des forces
américaines en mai prochain
de leurs côtés les talibans se sont
engagés à ne pas laisser des groupes
terroristes agir depuis des zones qu'ils
contrôlent et à ne plus attaquer les
troupes américaines qui comptent encore
2500 hommes mais cette donne pourrait
changer avec l'administration de joe
biden cette dernière souhaite notamment
évaluer le respect par les insurgés de
leur engagement sur le terrain les
observateurs constatent toujours des
attaques nombreuses compte
les forces afghanes côté politique les
négociations de paix ouverte entre les
talibans et le gouvernement afghan n'ont
pour l'instant donné aucun résultat
concret les rebelles houthi du yémen à
ne figure plus sur la liste américaine
anwar des groupes terroristes décision
annoncée vendredi par l'administration
maiden entrée en vigueur aujourd'hui les
rebelles yéménites étaient considérés
comme une organisation terroriste sous
leur administration de donald trump une
marche en arrière diplomatique plus
pacifiques malgré la poursuite des
combats sur le terrain
pierre pissavy yvernault en quelques
semaines les outils change de statut
auprès de washington dans les derniers
jours de son mandat est donald trump
décide de les placer sur la liste noire
des groupes terroristes
mais dès son arrivée à la maison blanche
joe biden annonce un réexamen urgente
cette décision le secrétaire d'état des
états unis a confirmé il ya quelques
jours la décision de la nouvelle
administration qui entre en vigueur ce
mardi
nous avons entendu les mises en garde
des nations unies des groupes
humanitaires et des membres des deux
partis politiques représentés au congrès
parmi d'autres selon lesquelles ce
classement aurait pu avoir un impact
dévastateur sur l'accès des yéménites
aux biens de première nécessité comme la
nourriture ou le carburant
aujourd'hui de nombreux groupes
humanitaires travaillent dans les zones
contrôlées par les outils ce revirement
de washington leur permet de ne plus
être considérés comme complices et donc
d'éviter d'être poursuivis par la
justice des états unis
une décision qui devient officiel
quelques jours après l annonce de la fin
du soutien américain à la coalition
saoudienne contre les outils au yémen à
des rebelles et qui continuent en ce
moment même leur offensive pour
contrôler le nord du pays
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
amélie bega à guillaume fils david luiz
inouïe et aux équipes techniques
raphaël gaboriau ainsi qu'aux équipes de
maxime rosières en usent rom on se
retrouve à 22 heures pour un point
complet sur l'actualité à tout soldat
[Musique]
on
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
j'entendais pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça il faut que
leur qu'istres groove la musique c'est
la traduction la plus poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie bat évidemment
on s'embête il faut sortir les notes de
leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance